but now the problem is every tool does a little bit of everything and so that's what causes all the confusion.
I'm sure you've experienced that.
So basically
Bark is meant to be a like business intelligence tool for us able to understand overall what our media is doing based on our profitability and you know, like that whole thing, right?
So that's what they do.
And of course, Chris is right to want to make sure that if we are making business related decisions off of the data, hey, shouldn't we make sure the data is accurate, right?
That is a very low level thing to correct if we decide that we want to continue using bark, right?
The other piece of it is bark is never going to
do is it's not an MMA tool, the way Prestian did, right?
You're like, that's a whole different story.
And I don't think profitability in CAC and all like, well, CAC is separate.
Profitability at the individual product level, that's not something we're going to use Prestian for, which makes me feel like just doesn't understand how to use bark, which is addressable, but good to know that that's where we stand.
Right.
Yeah.
That's what I was thinking as well as I don't I don't think pressing it would be the ideal replacement for that.
Talking to Chris directly.
Yes, because he has his hands and everything and understands the economics of everything as well.
So like he would definitely be that middle ground point of contact to figure that out.
So that's why I was like very receptive to him like intercepting him essentially.
Totally.
And so we don't touch Prestian in this conversation at all.
Let's separate that so that we don't have to like keep in complications, right?
The other side of it is Chris.
Chris is the person really who needs to determine what tool he likes using for individual product level and then total contribution margin profitability.
I know that he likes that tool polar.
I don't know, you've probably not even touched it because I don't even touch it.
It's like a Chris tool entirely, right?
Okay.
The main thing is, right?
I don't, we need to understand what where polar starts and ends and where bark starts and ends.
And if there is redundancy, if one of them can take over for the other, because if that's the case, right?
So like, for example, there could be a world where, and I'll say this to Chris too, there could be a world where polar
is just Chris's business intelligence tool as a CFO, right?
And then we use bark and pression to make like marketing level decisions, cap acquisition, what we're investing in, we're not investing in product, right?
And so that would be my suspicion is that, and then what ends up happening then is Chris has to decide does he want to pay for two tools, Polar and Bark, or does he want to make bark
accurate and useful to his polar tools like what he's using polar for and then we just have one system which is bark.
Okay, okay, yes, that makes sense.
I think there's definitely probably going to be overlap between the tools, but one is more geared towards like, obviously probably pollers more geared towards CFOs, whereas barks more geared towards marketers.
So there's maybe overlapping data, but how the tools are leveraged and could be different.
So I can definitely dive in, get an understanding of the two, have a conversation with Chris to get his perspective to which certain lines of yours.
But that way I can just kind of meet him where he's at and understanding and then help him kind of
get that we're trying to leverage these tools slightly differently.
If it comes to that, if there's no like, hey, they're basically the exact same thing, the UIs are similar, we're getting daily emails with the same metrics and they align, then like it makes sense to pick one over the other and not publish this leverage.
Super line there.
Thanks for the clarity, because I was like, it's just kind of got.
Yeah, spider webby, like it's just going a few different directions.
And then for
Oh bridge just how the conversation with bridge guy over bridge tool seems pretty Useful for our needs especially with us ramping up content creator and influencer partnerships.
They can have custom bridge pages That can make those experiences a little bit more unique to their personal brand.
I think you know computer leverage with our
existing social placements to drive warranty sign-ups is that something like a 30% I guess like warranty sign-up rate and then like a 10% conversion rate overall of the of the traffic that like signs up
Yeah, of the traffic that signs up for the warranty, 10% of them ultimately end up driving more revenue, which kind of justifies the cost of the product.
And he walked through the demonstration with me.
This is the second call.
We'll walk through the pricing infrastructure.
So it all seems
Aligned.
I think only concern is like some of the activations they have that are more like physical real-world marketing for event activation things to do with retail things that QR codes and packaging from a digital side it seems like we can stand things that pretty quickly on the physical side it seems like there will be a lot of large business decisions to make on how to implement it from that standpoint and he also let me know that they'll do a
Kind of like a two month opt out like if we're not seeing the value then we don't have to opt into the full 12 month month a month or annual contract that they typically have brand sign.
So it seems like there's a bit of leverage and there is a
You know someone there personally, they know Sharma Brands, they're offered us a 10% discount on the monthly.
So it seems like there's a lot of incentives here to get us to do business with them, but just kind of want to hear your thoughts on it.
I think it makes sense to implement from a digital standpoint, kind of replace it's a better link tree if that makes sense, but just wanted to hear if you had any insight to your thoughts.
Yeah, I guess maybe I, I don't know, do you know how much it overlaps with loud crowd?
Do you know anything about loud crowd?
I don't know anything about loud crowd.
Can you have Anastasia walk you through loud crowd?
You should know it anyway.
But then just see what the differences are.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, I think a lot like loud crowd.
Yeah, it seems like there's quite a few yeah creator storefronts.
Yeah, yeah, and I could definitely see what the overlaps is here.
Yeah, they all have their own little differences.
Yeah, like the USP's a little bit different with bridge, but like they'll do offer this one crossover between the tools for what I can see so far.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
That makes it easy because I was like, yeah, like I can see it fitting, but we may have some tool in this like ecosystem already that is kind of doing the same thing.
It comes across.
Yep.
Yeah, exactly.
Cool.
I did send over the weekly report.
I don't anticipate you had time to like view it.
Right now, so I can, you wanted to walk me through it.
Yeah, for sure.
So I got the executive summary up top, kind of showing the spin for this week versus previous week, not the week of week labeling, burnt down, paid me delivered.
Can you add the year over year, like week over week and year over year is important for me.
Okay, in the executive summary, I do have your over your towards further down, but I can.
Yeah, yeah.
So there is a table for it, but just not referenced in the year.
Yeah, let's me go.
I'm just in the executive summary now.
So what is dragging down.
Is it metastill?
Um, yes, I would say men are still bringing down the efficiency overall.
It's gotten better over the weekend.
Over that seven day period, it didn't look too strong, but over the weekend, that's where we saw the biggest uplift.
And it's kind of maintaining through the week.
So we started to see better traction there.
We did pull down spin, like Jake mentioned.
about right at 3100 bucks and starting to see believe red light hat and the body care and supplements campaigns pick up tell him to go ahead and allocate the scale budget towards those campaigns since we're seeing a lot of traction there yeah
That's good.
Okay.
And then how are the bundles doing?
Bundles, it's still a little too early to tell since they are higher ARV products than a whole lot of spin there.
And what they're going to, I think they want us towards the end of last week.
But yeah, I haven't, not anything notable yet.
Do we, are they working on creative?
Yes.
They had some deliverables from what I
Remember earlier this week on a call.
They had some stuff that they wanted to run by Laura, which I think they reached out to her on.
Okay.
And I just, I'm, I need convincing to not completely shut off app 11.
Yeah, I would say TikTok over Abloven.
Abloven definitely has a stronger efficiency over like there's more there, but after we started using our own money, Abloven's performance just kind of went down down.
But Abloven and TikTok for sure, long shopping buck.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'm fine with like shutting it off for the summer and just like putting more into like CTV and that kind of stuff to like build the funnel up.
Yep.
No, I totally agree.
Um, I think that we can reallocate those dollars more effectively, like during the summer, we want to test other things anyway.
And we can see that clearly these channels aren't producing much.
So like since we're in the summer of testing, we might as well allocate that spend towards something that is going to produce.
That's right.
Um,
Okay.
And then the other piece is I, so we're going to do our Labor Day sale.
I'm aligning on the dates right now.
I love your perspective on like what happened last year.
Winds losses like a little summary so that we can then kick off with like last year's performance information and then learn how to make it better.
Okay.
Cool.
And then same thing with like top-performing creative.
If we have that, that will be helpful.
Yeah, let's just prep for Labor Day.
Okay.
Cool.
We can definitely dig in.
Motion.
Who are we getting contact with Chris to get access to motion art?
No, I actually have motion to give to you.
So give me one second.
I may have it.
You may and you may not, because that's world and Chris is usually faster at that stuff.
Okay, here we go.
Let me see.
I don't know yet.
Yeah, yeah, I've heard Jordan.
There it goes.
Oh, it says invite membership already exists.
No, that is all needed.
So most of it came through when I did not accept.
Let me see.
We send it.
Yeah, because it expired.
I did just fine.
Yeah, yeah.
Go ahead and announce it.
My chest.
but also to note, since kind of on the topic of creative, Meta UGC creators are starting to pull really well.
I mean, we are indexed more heavily on UGC content on Meta than other channels, but that was one thing that they mentioned.
They kind of have a good backlog of stuff to test through with Anastasia.
So I think that's kind of gonna be the focus while I get some of this other stuff delivered.
It's to get more of the,
I guess, light listing, influencer content.
Tested in in the article.
Yeah.
Okay.
That sounds great.
And that's with agency H should also be helping with that and anesthesia.
Yes.
Exactly.
Yeah.
They've reached out to anesthesia in one of the group chats regarding some updates on the tracker that they've been using.
Perfect.
Okay.
I'm going.
I just deleted you in motion.
I'm just going to react you.
Okay.
Thank you.
Tell me if you get that email.
When I deleted your access, did you get an email that you got deleted?
Oh no.
Okay, that's good.
Because I just deleted some things that might be controversial, but I don't care.
All right, so you got motion and then yeah, I'd love to just get like, uh, get our ducks in a row for Labor Day.
Yeah, I think actually if we have a strong day today, we might actually catch up.
Yes.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm, today so far we're at one.
It's a little soft.
It means about the same as yesterday, but that's fine.
We just need to.
We got it.
Looks like we may have sent an email yesterday because we got a bomb at like 5 p.m.
Oh, sure.
Yeah, sure.
Up 36% I could be.
Yeah, but like that's up, I think, to the previous day.
I'm just looking at the like, I guess, sessions.
Yeah, orders are up 56.
Yeah, today's good.
Yeah, we should.
I mean, let me month to date doesn't include.
It doesn't include the 23rd.
So today's 23rd.
Yeah.
So reporting at 2% if we continue strong, then like we should definitely cut that down for another chunk in about seven more days to kind of pump it.
So it's right.
And we need to have a strong weekend, which I think we will now that things are a little bit
Yeah, get email and SMS up to date.
Let me actually, I think I have their numbers here.
I'm catching everything up here now.
Okay.
Yeah, today's definitely, and spend is overall month to date.
Here we are.
That's fine.
I think we were pacing higher on the last update for month and date versus year.
Yeah, we got to just cut that Pinterest.
Like get it, get it in line.
We got to be spend last make more and that's like waste and Pinterest and Apple oven is stupid.
Yeah.
So we'll get continue to cut those at the fact.
And then once we have more, I understand the argument of like, oh, it's helping top of funnel or whatever.
I don't fully believe that.
And to once we have pression, then we can actually make more informed decisions versus like a feeling that we have.
Yeah.
And I totally agree.
I feel like a top of funnel channel that's supposed to be top of funnel, like awareness play.
We're looking for, we came on to have loving looking for direct conversions, not to pump awareness.
Right.
And I've seen it perform well for other brands.
There's just takes there's a lot of creative testing involved with it to get to that point.
So we probably just have to ramp up what we're testing on that channel.
But I don't want to increase spend and doing that.
I think there's a way to do it.
Testing other products at lower spends until we get traction and then go for that.
But on the pressing piece, like, what is it waiting on first and verify data?
Do we have to like have a call with them?
I think so.
Yeah, I think we need to schedule a call.
Like if you're in, once you get in the system, it's going to like force you to call.
Yeah, like I've been clicking and I like I got that prompt once.
No, it says we will be reaching out to schedule call with you.
And I haven't seen any communication and like I think pretty sure we followed up with pressing it.
Have Ari go and like fix that because we should have.
I mean, I'll email a CEO if that doesn't go any more, but... Is it Paul?
Yeah, Paul.
It's going through the rest of your updates here.
Oh yeah, let me see.
You should also save this link and put it in the chat.
Is it easier in the chat or if I slack you a link?
Yeah, you can put it in the chat.
I'll start.
This is the CRM weekly update that I have Sharma send me.
Okay.
Yeah, so they're at 77% to goal as of Tuesday, yesterday.
And what are we at?
There's 31 days.
Yeah, so all right.
So we're at 71% to the month as of yesterday.
So they're actually pacing.
I think, yeah, just, I wanted to go in with one, give more clarity of visibility into the performance of the channel.
I see what's coming into Northean, but I also know like that's going to be different than what like, obviously Shawna sees as the impact.
But yeah, I just want to make sure that we, yeah.
can interact around and whatever we can do in the next seven days to drive more push more you know campaigns come with something then you know definitely down to explore it and they're just moving forward in general having more visibility.
Yeah agree and that's great and if you want I can actually even add you to our weekly's which would be good for you to get the full picture.
Yeah I mean you can like put those as optional but
I think as long as you're checking in with Elise and like looking at the, yeah, it is, let me get onto Tuesday as yeah, let me just add you.
Thank you for stepping up on that stuff.
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
And then Awin and Estasia, how are you sinking with her?
Um, the base is like, I reach out to her and chat and just kinda hate it.
Can we scale this up and she's definitely doing a crazy view-strawbing managing it because of the efficiency.
Does get better as we spend.
Last seven of the channel did come down a bit as she's like started to ramp up and add more vendors that make the last one she had some questions on.
Where's our?
Between the three of us.
There was one more she was trying to bring on, but she pinged all of us.
I thought I gave her enough insight.
on moving forward.
There it is.
TV scientific.
There's another one.
Get healthy you.
It's a new affiliate test.
She said it on July 15th on Tuesday.
I did follow up with her on my thoughts, but I don't know where that's actually just been her.
Yeah, I'll just hang out.
And then my last question for you is on the creative for CTV.
Catch me up on where we're at there.
Yep.
So Shaman has been briefed.
They did just reach out this morning asking for creative specs.
I let Lord know to put that.
in the doc, but we're in the brief she sent over, but I think she got left out, but I said over the doc I put together and breaking down what CTV said to us for requirements and kind of a creative approach.
So I should have that with Sharma, it's with them.
So they're working, should be working on those creatives moving forward.
They've got the requirements.
Send this back to her team and let you know if we have any further questions.
So that was as 29 minutes ago.
Okay.
Great.
Thank you.
I, yeah, I keep seeing more and more ads.
Oh, the other big thing is I can't recall if this was in the brief, but I do think it's really important for us to include all of our awards.
We have so many laurels.
We have like Oprah's Choice, Vogue, L Beauty Awards on like a million of our products.
So we have rights to all of that.
So that should definitely be shown.
Where can I get a comprehensive list of all, so I can just empower them like, hey, here's all publications, here's all their awards.
I think they actually have the link to the laurels folder.
If not, like, put it in and tell them and then tell them if they have the link to the folder.
I think they do.
To laurels folder that has all of the laurels that they're called award laurels, I'll put it in the chat.
Okay, that's what I thought you were saying when I was like, oh, maybe she may.
I know they're too similar and likely.
Okay.
Let's see.
Thank you.
All right.
What else do you need from me?
How can I be helpful to you?
That's it.
There may have been questions.
There was one question and I need to look in our threads and you popped up yesterday.
Oh, Bing, who's managing Bing?
Because it's Crackling Club.
I saw that in the chat.
No one is a short answer.
It was being managed by our old agency, Block and Tam, and no one is managing it right now.
So do you have access to anything?
I don't.
Chris gave Sharma access.
I need to get access.
I should have asked for it yesterday, but they have access and we're all already went in and got some recommendations.
I just didn't know if I could greenlight it or not because somebody else is managing it, but
We'll go out and get back to there.
That's all yours.
Cool.
Sweet.
Yeah, I was, I believe last night.
Last night I needed to clear the on.
Perfect.
Um, and then are we off Pinterest entirely?
Um, we, it's down to 50 bucks a day.
We talked about pausing, but no confirmation there.
So I'll follow up with are you on that to see if we pause it down, then work on reducing TikTok and app love and spend until we can kind of phase those out.
Um, I don't think that
I told them, on TikTok to focus on one product, they're trying to manage two products in low budget spend and we've got high of knees across the board, except for body care and supplements, so it's like
You're really splitting that budget teeth in to move the needle and the body sculptors showed the most signs there.
So I feel like we should keep you going at that until we get the channel to a better spot.
And then app love and we were only had only tested the one products.
I need to tap in to see what other campaigns they've watched since that conversation.
And then
So believe that was Tuesday last week that we kind of went in.
And yeah, so I'll follow up with them on what the strategy direction for those channels and bring bringing spend on.
Yeah, okay, great, great, great, great.
Same thing with Pinterest.
I just feel like we didn't we don't have proper creative and Pinterest either.
No, and yeah, Pinterest is another, like I don't know if we have, I guess there is now the time to be focusing in deploying resources into those channels is my question to you.
Exactly.
I don't think so.
Okay, yeah, I'm aligned with you there.
So we can revisit those since there is going to be a bit more investment required.
and I feel like getting Meta in a better place and putting more attention.
The resources there is a better use of our time and dollars.
So, because if we turn Meta around like and get that, you know, three percent increments, it's a much larger swing on performance and top line impact than trying to dial in Pinterest and Apploven and take talk and a couple of grand a day collectively.
And also, we get nowhere.
So, yep, we're online there.
Okay.
Perfect.
Yeah, I think CTV just deserves all of our attention right now.
Yeah, I agree.
I'd rather see what the opportunities are there versus continuing to spend wheels and things that we haven't seen traction.
And then also TikTok on the year spin is like 200 can.
I don't feel like that is like we've kind of got enough conclusive evidence there for my opinion to make a decision on whether it's worth it.
I agree.
So, at least for now, but yeah, we'll line there and then we can just start putting more attention to CTD, take away from those, making sure we've got enough creative resources for the primary channels.
Yep, yep, exactly.
All right.
Amazing.
Okay, great.
Anything else for me?
No, ma'am.
Appreciate time.
Thank you.
Appreciate your time.
All right, thank you very much.
Peace.
Navigating everything, okay?
For YouTube, you find it everything.
I don't know, I don't know.
The rights to the access to the interior of the great pyramid.
And they also owned some of the right to Shaco Canyon and a certain area in Great Britain.
They didn't have the right to go walk up here on.
In 2000, they go 2018.
And I got to stop all my guys with these cars.
No, you lost your goods.
No.
No, man.
But they had all the tickets.
They had all the ARB teams.
And black hats.
And they stopped me going into the area.
I was told by the guy that he couldn't go there.
I thought he lost me.
They stopped me.
And I said, let me ask you a question.
I'm not on the back.
Why can't I come over here?
But again, the NASA narrative comes up again.
So India, Egypt, the Grand Canyon, Chaco Canyon, as four places that I know now that NASA has had some level of control on antiquities and ancient knowledge.
and don't forget space, you know, all these videos that have been surprising.
You know, this is astonishing.
So let's get to the function of this.
Let's just go back in time, 40,000 years ago.
Did this, in your opinion, happened in a short amount of time?
Did it come from the skies and just kind of bend itself into the surface?
Or what was the engineering bottom line of the function of this thing?
But when you go into some of the ancient texts, you read a new text that, though, is with his father, Gautley, who gone his auntie in the Sumerian taverns.
And his father tells him it's time to fulfill the plan that we know of, or that he know of.
He said, give your crew together and get into the great ship of the master.
And, you know, go handle this.
It's from what the business was.
He said that the fountains have received
and the temples were coming up out of the mud.
So he tells the sun fell to get his crew together, get into the sky ship, and they sail upwards into the sky.
They don't go across the ocean.
They go up until the planet literally disappears.
This is in the text.
Then when they get to the place appointed, they said, be neat, Gus.
We see the children of the land of camp that talk about ancient camping, pre-dagnastic Egypt, proposed called Egypt by the Greeks, was actually called camp.
He says he can see the people beneath, down, so they decide to descend.
So again, this is the word that's demonstrating height and being above something altitude, they descend down to the land.
When he opens up the doors and it should if it starts to come out, these people, they call them barbarians, come to attack them, probably because they're trying to protect their territory.
He says he raised his staff and sends out a ray of vibration
Starling and spill a sprang some stone of a mountain.
So he has this kind of a stun, non-leafed stun weapon.
So I started looking into a kind of weapon like this actually even exists today.
And I found the active denial system in the US military.
I was in the imperial system.
It's in my book.
I wrote this in my book five years ago.
The image of the analysis from the military, the length of the source, everything's in there.
And they could send a beam of ray of energy at a group of people looking to attack or riot, and they can actually freeze them in their tracks, they can make them feel like they're in pain, they can make them vomit, they can be voices in their head, they can make me feel like they're on fire.
It's a retelling non-alegal frequency that both says he has this 36,000 years ago in the ancient text.
But now he says, now I'm hearing his people, he says they begin to grovel at his feet because he's showing them his magic signs that translates today into advanced technology.
So they believe he's a God.
But as they grovel at his feet, he stops them and says, no.
I'm not a guard, I'm a son of Atlantis, and I'm here to bring you back up to a high level of civilization, meaning at one point in the past prior to this great catastrophe, probably the underdrying, the underdrying system.
They were already a high civilization, and he had been there before, but he says I'm here to bring back up to a higher level.
And he says, long we stay to camp, get long and get long again, so we stay here for years, years, years, helping to rebuild this civilization after this great flood.
And then he said to his team, and it was done, spread out around the world and duplicate what we did here.
And that's why you see similar temple styles, similar structures, similar pyramid styles all over the planet.
They were the master architects, and they had humans that they had worked with and trained and taught the sacred knowledge of this construction technique, these masons, that them along with these other beings called
On the ship too, work with the people to help construct these magnetic sites all over the world.
I would always have a huge floor.
If you don't have to ride all the covers, you just can't really blow your budget.
There are cases of ease, and then there's zascies trying to check the thing that case of ease.
Back with their famous chicken fingers, jeeps, and I hope.
Hello, it's your favorite fourth up here.
Don't forget to hit that subscribe button, if you join the fastest growing community on YouTube.
Remember, nightcap doesn't happen without you, so please subscribe, and we'll make sure to make sure.
Browns can you think it predicted you're in a training camp that's QB1.
Cleveland's quarterback battle is beginning as a bout to begin with the start of the 2025 training camp.
Rookie's at bed, have a vision and reported to Barrel.
As you keep things up, Mary K. Cabin predicts that Kenny Picket will have the upper hand for the end camp.
Kenny Picket still has a slight edge in terms of being number one on the depth chart, adding in a training camp that would change Mary K. Cabin.
If the gospel would have come to clean the ground.
Keep the gospel.
Yes, yes.
Yes, he is.
Listen, she's a pop variety.
And pop it.
There's some reported that when they speak about, because they covered it for so long.
Yes.
That's her change later.
When she starts talking about the cowboy, take it to the bed.
Yeah.
Every time they take it, they're going to take it to the bed.
It used to be that way with an animal shed.
We used to do this for her.
I don't know if she still does that.
Does the ants feel them?
But when he talks, going in like yada, Mary Kate happens to go out until you go to sleep.
I'm gonna say the quote about you guys.
I like what they don't.
I like the fact that they put some things out most of the time.
It's all smoke and air.
Coming back to the Los Angeles glippers, a senior insider broke the story into it as now shoms.
One day, Chris Paul decided to return here to the Los Angeles glippers.
When Chris Paul wanted to stay near his family in Los Angeles this upcoming season and the Clippers needed another reserved guard.
They needed someone at the point guard position to come up with it.
So it made it a perfect match up for it.
We needed multiple sewers such as Milwaukee, Dallas, Charlotte, all the stress interest in Chris Paul in the last few weeks.
But now the ability to join a contender, L.A., the history.
We should get through this together.
I'm working at now.
I'm fighting him.
I'm a deep team.
I'm totally pissed off.
Very much to understand.
It will come fluctuate night to night.
Might play.
He might not play on some night.
But they go to the start.
Come off the bench and be a club and play a player.
This is something that could have a pretty proper role coming off that clippers band.
Yeah, I know his role may look a little bit different, but I'm a sucker for them to stay with you by the car.
You know what I mean?
I'm already the clips that have been circulating around the Internet of those locks that he clippers in the thought that we're going to get to see a new version of that once again.
But this time it's going to be Chris's 21st season in the NBA.
Do you have any reported to suggest that we should be thinking about this, that it's his last ride?
Like I'm told, Chris Paul is expected to retire after this season.
He's going to go through training camp, go through the season.
Like he always does.
See how he goes.
But his plan is for this to be his final season.
He told the Pat McLean show a month ago that he wanted to be back.
And near his family, now he's back in Las Vegas.
He got to do just that.
With a federal story, we'll finish to a 21 year illustrious Hall of Fame career.
And it's so good to see him back in Clippers, Unicorn.
That's going to be a treat for all of us fans, Shoms.
Thank you so much for being talking to you.
I get a little bit later in the show.
It's hard to fathom that this could be the last run in Shoms' day because he went for nearly 9.7 times this per game as the Spurs veteran leader.
And this is what gets me.
He started in all 82 games last days, and it was just the second time he's done that in his career.
He also did that in 2014-15 when he ranked 6th in MVP voting in 2016-24.
The Los Angeles Clippers, of course.
Since we say hello to our friends, Brian and Norris Kendrick, Perkins, Bobbie, and Mark, it's always good to have you in the studio, my friend.
Brian, I am going to start with you here and talk about the fit.
We're looking at an incredibly deep, if not a little bit of an older Los Angeles Clippers team.
How do you see C.P.
through slotting here?
Well, this is a great value sign for the clippers.
They get a first ballot hall of favor really for a bargain basement contract because he was prioritizing staying home in Los Angeles ahead of playing time and roll.
He could have gone to Milwaukee as Sean's mentioned and gotten more guaranteed playing time.
That's not going to be the case here.
He from what I understand he's not going to have guaranteed playing time.
There wouldn't be nights
where James Harden and their backup, Chris Dunn, get the minutes at point guard, and Chris Paul might not play at all, which is something you've never seen before.
He has understood that.
He understands that he is going to be in that spot that he has, and he wants to be a competitive team in the marketing, he wants to play a nearest family.
And look, there haven't been an understanding of James Harden.
He and James Harden didn't have the greatest stuff.
relationship when they were in Houston, Australia, but hard is on board with this signing.
They went to him with it first.
He understands that he played the fifth most minutes in the league last year and anything
The flickers can do to support and protect him as well, and that's what this move is.
Okay, you said a whole lot of important stuff, right?
They're right.
In fact, I had the most interest in work, and I thought that a guy who started an A to B's last season is okay with his role now to be coming off of the bench.
You think you're a basketball perspective?
Because for his family, I am so very happy for Jane and the whole crew that Chris Paul is closer to home here.
We're a basketball perspective.
Is this the right fit for this final season?
Some stuff just cause more except the airfare and two flights this summer I had to download now.
Wait, no house show you when bed's not.
New?
The psychology-based weight loss company?
Yes, new and combined medication and behavior change.
So you can lose the weight and keep it up.
And it starts at just $149.
Yeah, it's a smart way to lose weight.
Why did no one tell Florida drivers about this new rule?
If you are currently in church, driving less than 50 miles a day to live in a qualified zip code, you can get an extremely high discount.
Additionally, if you have no tickets, I mean, if you have not received the ticket in three years,
Do you get even more discounts?
But do you think your auto insurance company will tell you that?
I don't think so.
Now listen to this.
When Miranda, a good friend of mine, entered her zip code in comparisons.org.
She was shocked.
She found out her local insurance agent was ripping her off.
Yes, literally.
Ripping her off.
She actually managed to reduce her insurance premium by 50%.
Now this is the rule that everyone needs to know.
Never, ever.
buy insurance without comparing rates and discounts from an unbiased source first.
Survey data indicates it's possible to save more than $500 per year on current rates.
You know how?
So comparisons.org put together this three simple six second quiz.
And at the end, you'll get a list of the top offers that are catered to your specific driving preferences, zip code, and more.
You can save up to 50% of your current trends.
So what are you waiting for?
Scan the QR code right now and stop getting ripped off.
By the way, you're never likely to hear current policy.
If you already make your current policy, you can very easily cancel
So simply scan this QR code right now and enter your zip code and fill out some basic information in order to review codes and discounts from top com Simply pull out your phone right now and scan this QR code to save up to 50% on your car insurance
to stay bomber in the last ends of this clip.
They have officially become the nursing home for the NBA.
Now I'm serious, because if we think that this is about to move the needle for the glimpses for us being a belliger, not just a title contender, but competing at the Southwest in conference, it's not that I get it.
Chris Paul, he brings great value whether he's playing or whether he's on the bench being at an extent to no time loop.
But when I look at their roster, I look at a guy like Duhin, yes, he's a guy that can defend at a high level, but the flippers look old.
And they still, to me, have a problem in their wing position when it comes down to death from guys that could compete and play at a high level on the defensive side of the days.
Offensively, they got enough to put up points.
They're going to have a good regular season, but it comes down to them competing in the Western Conference especially when they get postseason time.
Can I compete with the rights of the Houston O.K.C.W.A.L.A.?
I just don't see.
Look, I mean, this team, it goes as Kauai Liner goes, right?
Ultimately, how healthy is Kauai Liner?
And that is going to dictate what the Los Angeles Flipers are able to do.
So if we're talking about 2017 and looking at all of these guys on this roster, this would be a four-middle for a middle group.
But this is a little bit of an older group that we're looking at now.
Bobby, can you just show us what this rotation could look like for the Los Angeles covers?
Well, it's certainly deep here.
It's bigger.
Sure, that noise was done.
I did a couple times with my asses.
The ball I had is pulled this all of that and it's hard so it slipped some so I was like it hurt when it slipped up.
Yeah.
I just decided I was going to risk hurting myself more than helping myself trying to use that ball.
And so it was going to be changing since I didn't grab five.
It's like a little soccer ball, so it's really good.
Yeah.
It worked okay, but I was happy.
I feel like I did behind my back a little bit, but it's not here for me.
I'm glad.
Because you didn't want to do it at all.
Because yeah, I'm the first buddy that did the last one.
We'll go to the replay soon.
I'm glad.
You and your buddy didn't do it for a week now.
He'll like it a little bit.
It's a great appointment.
So, I was like, we visit today.
Is it a loudhouse on the way?
I don't know if you want to go over there.
How are you doing, lady?
I'm good, how are you?
This is my mom, my brother, I'm with you.
Oh, hi, mom.
Hi.
How's it going?
We're down and just palms with this for another week, but otherwise all the kids have gone home and it has to start to fill in again.